de chanel la doyenne christian lacroix
d'y arriver mais je défends le portrait
de 15 maisons en activité
être installé à paris présenter deux
collections par an avec 50 modèles
minimum et employer au moins dix
ouvrière tel est le dernier cahier des
charges à remplir pour accéder au label
haute couture chapeauté par la puissante
chambre syndicale de la haute couture 7
à première vue un drôle de paradoxe en
matière économique
une activité hautement déficitaire 250
millions de chiffre d'affaires annuel
pour 400 d'investissement si aujourd'hui
300 clients enduro souffre dit s'écrit
après guerre à s'offrir une robe à 500
mille francs
le tarif haute couture le prestige lié à
l'une de ses griffes
au revoir qu'un formidable train de
produits dérivés le prêt-à-porter la
maroquinerie et surtout les parfums
constituent de formidables mahbod de
l'industrie du luxe à la française reste
y met à 20 milliards de francs seulement
voilà depuis dix ans la concurrence
américaine et italienne sur le créneau
prêt à porter a taillé des croupières de
l'établissment un peu endormi sur ce
formidable maker dans le rôle du tocsin
jean paul gaultier et thierry mugler de
créateurs ont été appelés à la rescousse
cette année ils sont invités à vérifier
dans la cour des grands les avec leurs
propres règles le sur mesure une
nouvelle race de couturiers qui pourrait
en appeler d'autres
ou tenter de sauver la poule aux oeufs
d'or